this is my home this is my kitchen
this is my family tilly
jack holly
and of course my wife tana
[Music]
you may think you're the busiest person
in the world but over this serious
i'm going to prove it's still possible
to cook stunning food at home
[Music]
my rules are simple home cooking has to
be easy
it could be fast it's got to be
delicious
so if you think you can cook amazing
food at home think again
these are the only recipes you'll ever
need breakfast
lunch and dinner
everything i know about cooking i've
learnt through hard work drive
and passion from the age of 17 i made
food my life and it's fair to say
that since then food has been the making
of me but the sort of cooking i made my
name with
intricate dishes made with the world's
finest ingredients is a million miles
away from the food i grew up on
for the first program in the series i'm
updating some of the home-cooked dishes
i absolutely adored when i was a kid
first up for breakfast at classic from
my childhood
stunning baked beans with fluffy potato
cakes
next a modern take in my favorite
childhood lunch fantastic fish fingers
and an irresistible chip buddy
my mouth is salivating and i've got
competition in the kitchen as mum helps
make dinner
dad shouldn't manny be doing the prison
because she's the better cook
excuse me when i was a kid this was my
dream dinner
super comforting shepherd's pie with
peas and carrots followed by a steamed
date pudding
with butterscotch sauce to die for let's
get this show on the road
this is my ultimate childhood food
breakfast lunch and dinner
first a breakfast to really set you up
for the day easy homemade spicy baked
beans
with deliciously light potato cakes
[Music]
the first big thing that i remember as a
kid was
bacon and beans so this is like a little
rendition
except we're using the most amazing
pancetta ernie come on
disappear go and chase some mice now
panel get nice and hot
i'm gonna turn these beans into
glamorous beans pancetta into the pan
lightly season that it's cured so it
doesn't need
that much seasoning
now start frying off that pancetta
it's amazing how the individual tastes
of baked beans they're
somewhat bland so i always like to make
them a little bit more
spicy so a nice
finely chopped chili with
the seeds chili in
now a little bit of garlic
crushed phenomenal
[Music]
get that bacon really nice and crispy
fry off the chili and the garlic
and then onions my top tip for dicing
finely sliced downwards slice across
then cut down to simply dice
bacon onion chili garlic that flavor
all contained in that little pan once
you've sweated the onion off
a little bit of sugar in there the brown
sugar will start to caramelize
darken and enrich as well at the same
time
that looks beautiful now
a couple of tablespoons of cider vinegar
delays the pan
it's got that really nice powerful kick
to it now spice that up
with one of my favorite seasons
worcester sauce
bring that to the boil
and add your passata puree tomatoes
turn that down simmer the sauce to
reduce
then add in the classic baked bean
harrico beans
you can buy haircut beans dried or
canned they are packed with protein
and have a lovely soft texture turn down
the heat
and let the beans absorb all that
beautiful
spicy tomato sauce and just let that
simmer now
five or six minutes now for my potato
cakes they're a fantastic way to use
leftover boiled potatoes
and are so easy to make
i'm making a simple potato dough by
adding flour
and butter to the mash that gives it
that nice sort of
cakey texture and it goes from this
leftover ball potato
to this nice light
flowery potato heaven
take a nice spoon of potato lightly
flour your board we're going to fry
these
crisp on the outside and
just nice and fluffy in the center
now get your pan nice and hot
we'll start off with olive oil into the
pan
now put the butter around the outside
because it starts heating up by the time
it goes into the center
it's almost sort of nut brown gently
turn it over love that nice
light crisp they look beautiful
now take them out
oh potato cake in the middle
and a nice beautiful spoon
of beans growing up with beans on toast
as a
treat still to this day after all those
years
has not changed my love or attitude for
beans
especially cooked like that
my smoky spicy homemade baked beans with
light and creamy potato cakes
comfort and satisfaction on a plate
[Music]
coming up i'll be showing you more the
food that made me the man i am
but first here's a closer look at some
of the key ingredients you'll need to
shop for
to make my ultimate lunch and dinner
starting with pollock i grew up on
whitefish
like cod and haddock but today i'm using
pollock
whitefish like pollock has a wonderful
sweet firm flaky flesh
pollock's so versatile bake it batter it
cook it up in fish pie or even cut it
into strips for my fish fingers
which i'm cooking for lunch
[Music]
growing up i ate tons of lamb mince meat
it's generally from less expensive but
tasty cuts like neck and belly
you can use lamb mince in so many ways
in middle eastern copters
or mixed with mint for a twist on a
traditional burger
but as a kid i couldn't get enough of
shepard's pie and i'm making an amazing
version for dinner
[Music]
i eat potatoes almost every day as a kid
i love them
but remember it pays to use them
properly they come in three types
flowery waxy and all-rounders
for mash fried or roasting flowery
potatoes like king edwards are brilliant
for boiling or salads use waxy potatoes
like charlotte
[Music]
if you want the best of both worlds in
your kitchen go for an all-rounder like
desiree
i'm using them to make incredible oven
chips next
when i was growing up food in britain
was somewhat different to what it is now
no one had heard of organic you could
even buy avocados
in the shops where i lived paris
kitchens might have been cooking
nouvelle cuisine but
it certainly hadn't made any inroads
around our way malta my lunch when i was
growing up
was very plain pretty trashy but i still
love it
now and again fish fingers with a
delicious chip butty
the secret of a good chip butty
is in the potato now these are
desiree potatoes one of my first ever
jobs
was working in a chip shop i used to put
sacks and sacks of potatoes into the
rumbler which was then the potato peeler
all day long today i'm gonna do
something a bit healthier
for my oven chips with a twist simply
peel slice
and blanch for three to four minutes
drain season and cover well
with propeca spread evenly over an oiled
baking tray
and place into a preheated oven for 20
minutes
simple as that next up easy fish fingers
this is pollock a really nice firm
delicious
fish got the fish in finger size batons
of fish put them onto your plate
and just lightly salt them you can do
that literally 20 minutes
30 minutes before you start cooking the
fish it firms the fish up beautifully
and it allows it to become a little more
durable especially in the pan now for
the coating
start by thoroughly coating the fish in
seasoned flour
and then just roll it to get rid of
those little sharp
corners because then it stops those
corners
almost burning in the pan in to your egg
wash
and really coat them wonderful
and then this is dill goes brilliantly
well with a fish
and run the dill through my breadcrumbs
that makes it more aromatic
lay them onto your breadcrumbs
nothing wrong with the chip butty
nothing wrong with fish fingers
just give it a lovely modern twist
beautiful
once the fish fingers are thoroughly
coated they're ready to pan fry
and they'll need around three minutes on
each side
i want the fish fingers to be nice and
crispy get a really nice color on them
first and then we'll flip them over
and finish them with butter
bring the heat up into the pan and a
nice
little knob of butter that'll work
wonders with the breadcrumbs and the
dill
nice and carefully take them out
they look and smell incredible stay nice
and crispy
now to assemble my chip butty starting
with buttered thick crusty bread
a slice of bread mop up
that amazing flavor
on slice in half
never slice in an angle
my mouth is salivating beautiful
on with the ship buddy there's one thing
missing
and it signifies that i've never
forgotten the joy i've come for food
but my god that makes me feel like a
nine year old
excuse me for one moment when you want
to stuff my face
[Applause]
[Music]
homemade fish fingers and my ultimate
chip buddy
so simple to make but trust me it tastes
amazing
when i was a kid there wasn't a lot of
spare money in our house to spend on
fancy ingredients
but mum was brilliant at what she did
let me tell you so we had really tasty
hearty food
great cakes amazing puddings all made
with the freshest
ingredients that's right isn't it yes
let's get this show on their old town
we're cooking the kind of food
mum always dished up starting with a
family favorite
steam date pudding with a glorious
butterscotch sauce
they weren't cool desserts on those days
were they no it was puddings puddings
now i'm gonna sieve the flour would you
i'll chop here shawna chop those dates
please that was a favorite wasn't it
amazing sew it in
okay but it was almost like an
old-fashioned dessert wasn't this themed
and everything was sort of steam you had
jam really poorly mm-hmm
so the zest the orange makes that really
nice and fragrant sort of helps get that
richness to the suit
okay yeah brown sugar in
this is such an easy recipe yes looks
fantastic on the table
and then treacle cheek it in
wow look at that there's something quite
magical about a spoonful of treacle can
you add them in there please
thank you little dude and crack an egg
lightly whisk it
and mix that into the milk if i pour in
the egg
and the milk would you give that a
little mix up please yep thank you
nice nice and slow
don't go too fast
you see i always used to think that it
was an old-fashioned desert steamed
pudding do you ever remember me tumbling
around your knees trying to sort of get
in there
yeah so you like to lick the ball didn't
you all the time
yeah now lightly grease
the mold you're always willing to help
but not with washing up some things
never cheat i think it was allergic to
the soap
how was your excuse kids will enjoy this
tonight won't they
delicious paper that goes on
so the secret behind the parchment paper
is to keep that nice and tight tight yep
there we are good yeah oh
hey wash my hand
tightly cover with foil and place in a
pan of water and let it steam for around
two hours with a lid on
are you going to wash up gord
just for once wash up mister oh
dear goodness you like that smash
mom you handed it to me and you dropped
it come on
whilst mom forces me to break the habit
of a lifetime dude that's the thought
you're washing up it does that to you
here's how to make an amazing
butterscotch sauce to serve with the
pudding
add butter into a pan brown sugar
golden syrup
and a pinch of salt and vanilla seeds
melt and combine over a medium heat stir
in the cream and simmer
until thickened
that's the taste of my childhood inner
jug right there and it will keep in the
fridge
for a week
[Music]
now for the main course my all-time
favorite shepherd's pie
what's the secret behind a really good
shepherd's pie i would think the
vegetables you use and growing in it
so we're going to use leeks and onions
and then start browning off the mince
you know no color no flavor i've never
forgotten that you know that yep
so good have color gotta have color
otherwise it puts that grey tinge on the
shepherd's pie that
looks sick greasy and cheap and nasty
they don't want that do we and i know
you don't do cheaper nasty
let me clear your peelings now huh all
right thank you very much there's no
nails in there now is that
no
i remember your amazing shepherd's pie
and that lovely little restaurant used
to work in sheep street in stratfor
so you never got food sent back no
sometimes they complained that there was
no come on
no i'm tempted you never ever got a
complaint
no how long do you work at that
restaurant for
six shoes six years oh hello chilly
what are you cooking i'm gonna make okay
a sort of modern version of nanny's
shepherd's pie dad shouldn't manny be
doing the cooking because she's the
better cook
excuse me right mum would you would you
chop our onion please daddy
yeah oh gosh your eyes are gonna water
um no
daddy what's in this spot sorry in there
we got a delicious steamed
treacle and date pudding let's just
separate it for you
um how does skeletons call their friends
how do skeletons call their phone i'm
not too sure on the scalabone
on the skin tilly come on okay so two
cats are in a race
one is called one two three and the
other is called
under 12. who won
depends who's the fastest cat one two
three because under 12 cats sank
oh goodness tells why do you make a nice
cup of tea for honey do you want me to
disappear
thank you bye so give that a little fry
off okay
nice quiet to jokes they get worse
oh she's certainly having a bit of fun
booster sauce worcester sauce
that's gonna give that really nice spicy
seasoning
oh thank you oh you're okay yeah
tomato puree in you could put a ton of
tomatoes in this if you want
you could yeah put that mince back in
there once it's drained
i'm just going to put a little touch i
know you'll go crazy at this a little
touch of red wine
really well because i'm going to make it
nice and rich
okay reduce the red wine down yeah
and then start covering your mince with
your stock
now i'm going to bring it up to the ball
okay and then get some fresh rosemary
okay like it'll taste yes please
is it hot it's a little bit hot be
careful
oh i don't like the way i'm sorry
as it cooks out the wine and the alcohol
will disappear it'll be delicious
just me now gorge spring onions will
chop up
and that's going to go through the
mashed potatoes it's gonna sit on top of
that nice nicer i like that
savory yeah delicious mince that's laced
with all that red wine
nice so sprinkles into there please mum
and i'm gonna drain off the potatoes
hi there hello jack hello
hi hello hello jack have a nice day
school yeah oh
yeah yeah so we'll dry out those
potatoes and then mash them
nice oh can i mash them would you okay
um
holly slice a little knob of butter in
there for jack please
so what was the restaurant you worked
out there were you a chef
cook
i love a diplomacy were you a chef i was
a cook
exactly that not really
you used to help me with me as well
right your kids do no potatoes
these are nice and fluffy aren't they
aren't they and do you want mom look
delicious mashed potatoes yeah with no
lumps in there hey weren't you getting
it
huh it's great having you back in the
kitchen mummy now yeah
seriously brings back good memories
no just why'd you do that dad
i just want to fork it to get it nice
and spiky so i want that nice crispy
topping
and then lightly grate that cheddar
cheese on top
and that goes in the oven literally 20
minutes 180
minutes jack can you open the door
please that looks lovely doesn't it
even though you said you didn't like it
earlier okay
back in the day mama's meals all came
with two veg
and this is no different but with a
modern twist
braised peas and carrots with a
fantastic homemade mint butter
shepherd's pie glazed on top that looks
lovely doesn't it doesn't it
and then the carrots oh seated coats
that's why i didn't put carrots in let's
put them on the side i'll see
last job before serving pour that
gorgeous butterscotch sauce
over the pudding i'll take one at a time
that smells incredible this is my
ultimate childhood dinner
shepherd's pie with crispy cheese champ
topping sweet
buttery peas and carrots and a steamed
egg pudding
dripping in butterscotch sauce all
that's missing
are the family megan jack tilly holly
hello now take a seat again we're good
this is nan's recipe but modernized mum
how is that
it's very nice but i can't taste the
wine no that's right i said give it a
chance to cook out nunny
wow that's amazing do you like it
on that note cheers to nutty nanny thank
you for coming
yeah good to see you you're brilliant by
the way
you still didn't do the washing up there
are loads more great home cooking
recipes on my app
cook with me you can find it in the app
store good luck